all right before we get to our main
topic it's a new year in signs of
progress made by the president and his
administration are everywhere they're
like blooming it's like springtime a
little cold for that but remember a year
ago about when the liberal prophets of
doom were predicting that a trump
presidency would tank the stock market
kill jobs and mark America's retreat
from the world boy were they wrong and a
year later even the New York Times is
grudgingly admitting that due to Trump's
regulatory rollback business leaders are
now awash in a wave of optimism
manifesting in quote investment in new
plants equipment and factory upgrades
that bolster economic growth hallelujah
while forecasters are now readjusting
their projections for the year upward
good it doesn't always seem like it's
downward but this is now upward with
Trump and today's Wall Street Journal
above the fold reported that wages are
rising double the national average in
areas with some low unemployment after
years of stagnant wages cities like
Denver Minneapolis Fort Myers and Austin
are seeing paychecks start to swell
that's really good news here's my
prediction as Trump policies and the tax
cuts settle into the country our
economic news is only gonna get brighter
in 2018 it's only two days in and it
truly already feels like a happy new
year but now to the latest sexual
harassment opportunism coming out of
Hollywood to great fanfare they got
start treatment in all the magazines
newspapers a group of 300 female power
players in Hollywood announced what
they're calling The Times up initiative
it's an effort to fight sexual
harassment and other gender issues
across the country and in the
entertainment industry itself now it's
awfully convenient that these powerful
women many of whom knew for years about
the exploits of Harvey Weinstein and
others like him are now seeking to
cleanse
themselves from any guilt by association
with this type of grand role out in
gesture but beneath the girl-power
platitudes and the recruiting of hmm
Anita Hill to write up a blueprint to
end Hollywood sexual harassment it's
something all of this feels just like
another leftist political hot group like
it's almost like a political action
committee and at the heart of the times
up group is a Legal Defense Fund you're
seeing some of the photos with a
thirteen million dollar war chest that's
gonna be used to litigate harassment
claims and donors to fund this Meryl
Streep Reese Witherspoon Steven
Spielberg and other Hillary backers and
by the way several talent agencies well
under duress no doubt it's kind of like
what Jesse Jackson used to do with his
operation push well the Defense Fund is
being led by Tina Chen as far as I could
tell her only previous claim to fame was
that she was chief of staff - wait for
it Michelle Obama the whole effort is
being overseen by the National Women's
Law Center's legal network for gender
equality that's a mouthful but this
legal network was just created last
October according to the CEO of Fatima
graves she told The Huffington Post that
the group was founded in response to the
Trump presidencies quote all-out assault
on women's rights oh so I'm sure
conservative harassment victims will
feel very welcomed and protected there
let's be clear what this is all about
this is not just some beneficent effort
to protect women although the trappings
of it are there this is an obvious and
Craven attempt by Hollywood left us to
collect email addresses and other
information and organized for 2018 and
2020 time's up members include Ava
Longoria Natalie Portman rashida Jones
Kerry Washington and others who have
issued I think a hilarious challenge now
this is the big sacrifice they're asking
of women at the Golden Globes on Sunday
I know you're all going to be watching
intently women are being asked to wear
black and use the red carpet to argue
for racial
and gender equality black well work is
kind of classic but it's also can be
kind of depressing okay you think about
it given the fact that their entire box
office was dependent on the 40-year old
franchise of Star Wars and a 76 year old
Wonder Woman well perhaps the color of
morning is indeed appropriate women are
paraded down the red carpet they're
expected to look beautiful to smile
usually not to see much etc etc so what
Eva Longoria said to my colleague Kara
Buckley in the paper in the story that
was published yesterday she said we're
not willing to just be ornaments this
year we're not willing to go out and
sell this award show without asking any
of the big questions about power in
Hollywood don't you just want to tune in
well maybe this is a kind of a blatant
attempt to drive up Golden Globes
sagging ratings it's you can keep just
keep going down here after year but I'm
not sure it's even gonna work by the way
many of these women are the same women
who have made millions of dollars
flaunting their bodies for anyone who
cares to watch and at times even
watching these award shows talented
people there's beautiful folks women and
men but at times the dresses seem to be
defying the laws of physics right I'm
the double-sided tape how do they keep
that up for a while it was almost as if
Hollywood was creating a new category
and accepting on behalf of for the
deepest neckline is well I mean you can
wear whatever you want but then don't be
shocked when people including men stare
it's gonna happen now these same people
producers writers directors agents and
actors who have objectified women and in
some cases themselves there's suddenly
the moral conscience of the entire
country not just the entertainment
industry they're gonna safeguard women
across the country well what are we
gonna believe that they're looking like
what pilgrims this awards season what
are they gonna be wearing oh okay oh
that that's actually a good look on her
perhaps a little house in the Prairie
collection will be making its premiere
at the Golden Globes what are you
wearing Laura Ingalls Wilder well look
don't hold your breath you know who's
gonna do more help to help women than
anyone else this year by the way they
won't admit it but I'll tell you who
yeah there is Donald Trump an improving
economy is
for all Americans including women women
entrepreneurs remember women are half
the workforce if not more in certain
parts of the country they need a growing
economy wages going up optimism
confidence so the Hollywood crowd
they're great at stomping their feet and
fundraising for liberal causes but if
they really cared about their industry
well they'd stop hyper-sexualized women
and young people and until they do their
audience will continue to flee and seek
safe harbor elsewhere in other words
Hollywood times up
and that's the angle